My name is Misa Kuranaga.
I'm the principal dancer with Boston Ballet.
I'm from Japan.
I started taking ballet lessons at age seven.
My friends were taking ballet classes so I asked my mom to take me to the ballet class.
My mom didn't want me to dance so she took me to English class.
But right in front of English class, there was this ballet class going on...
...and I just didn't leave and I asked my mom to sign me up.
I knew right away this is what I like to do and I felt comfortable.
And somehow I knew, I had a feeling that I'm gonna be a professional dancer.
When I first got to Boston Ballet, I had still training from the School of American Ballet,...
...so I was very much Balanchine influenced.
And then in Boston Ballet, we do a lot of Balanchine...
...but of course we do a lot of classical and contemporary.
So we're really a wide range repertoire company and I needed to learn all that.
And I really enjoyed doing everything.
When you do a full-length ballet,...
...I think it's really important to really understand the role you are working on...
...and when I don't do that, I just feel like I'm faking something.
I do not like that.
And I really enjoy the process of getting to know the role...
...and getting into the role and then thinking about all the details and I just enjoy it very much.
Performance, definitely, will keep you going.
All the rehearsals that we are doing, of course they're hard.
Every day is a hard life for us.
It's not normal.
We have to go through so much pain, so much dedication.
You have to be really focused every day.
But once you get onstage and feel the energy from the audience...
...and the atmosphere of the theater and everything,...
...you just forget everything about pain and suffering and everything in the rehearsal.
That's how I keep going.